[Music]
it's been really amazing to see all the
reactions from the audience and the fans
and everybody it's just so inspiring to
see that and you know we're working
really hard we just want to make the
best game that we could ever make but
you know it's really exciting to be here
and I just feel really happy about it
we created this timeline between 2020
and 2077 and according to this timeline
there are four different visual styles
that are reflected in the fashion
architecture the design of the weapons
design of the cars and these four
different styles they are really
connected to events in the history so
using this as a backbone for the visual
design of night city we were able to
create a city that really feels like it
has a history it has different kinds of
people living there it's really
all kinds of architecture and I think
that really added to the realism of
night to be my man you made it you blown
up all over the news I just want the
money you got the chip all right started
up being one of the most anticipated
games currently out there is certainly a
big responsibility but the way we take
it at the studio it's encouraging us it
gives us the power to deliberate the
product that we are showing you here at
the gamescom
and we have a certain vision when it
comes to cyberpunk we want to create a
certain type of game the technology that
we're developing for gaming is certainly
allowing us to create more immersive
games as we envision with a cyberpunk
2077 the most challenging part of making
cyberpunk I think was to get from The
Witcher mindset to decide upon mindset
in order to create an experience that
really gets to play a hooked and make
him feel that he is actually part of the
story you need details as well because
they make it easier to realize for the
player and what kind of environment he
is knife city is future metropolis so in
order to create it very realistically
you have to make sure that it looks good
both at day at night but in all the
phases in between as well when it came
to night you also had to pay attention
that there are many light sources out
there there are nians all over the place
so we developed a global illumination
system that allowed light to bounce off
objects in order to make the world feel
more realistic and we certainly also use
the r-tx technology in order to improve
our shadow quality and the end effect is
mesmerizing you know when you design a
city
you really have to think of the
composition of the city and what does it
look like when you stand at the bottom
of a building what does it look like
when you stand on the top floor what
kind of view will you have and to
capture all this we use rendering
software to see every angle to really be
able to design complex environments much
better one thing that you will be able
to do inside of on 2077 is you will be
able to dynamically interact with your
environment even if you are playing out
cutscenes the player will not even
notice it's seamless between gameplay
and narrative moments we want to give
the player the control to actually
affect what is happening in the
conversation between two people which
exceeds the common dialogue options
known from the game so you might find
some objects around laying for you that
might influence how the scene will play
out game development is a creative
process we are running around many ideas
looking for those ideas that will make
this game as much fun as possible for
our community because this is what we
are all about we are creating games for
gamers we appreciate so much the
enthusiasm and it just inspires us a lot
I'm just really looking forward to next
year and that I really hope people will
take their car and just drive around
night city enjoy the level of detail
that we have put into this server from
2077
[Music]